today we have a very special guest
all three seasons of her series odd mom
out just
dropped on peacock well she's also my
dear friend and my children's aunt and
one of the most important people in my
life
is actress and comedian joel kargman
thank you i love you um
okay so we're gonna do some thanksgiving
uh
based news stories great based
i see what you did there okay across the
country
many first-time turkey cooks are
tackling their
very first birds
and wow there is a lot of messing up
going around
did i thaw that enough when do i baste
did i get all the goop out or did i
leave some goop in
wow
so cnn reports that whole foods has
teamed up with progressive
to offer turkey insurance this year it's
like
these two companies were like what's one
thing we can control
um if you bought a whole foods bird and
suffer a turkey fail you can get a 35
whole foods gift card back all you have
to do is send in the receipt and a photo
and description of your terrible turkey
joe what are you doing for thanksgiving
i'm supporting local restaurants by
ordering everything and cooking
nothing but we're all getting a turkey
day surprise this week from
zoom c net reports zoom is lifting their
40 minute limit on calls
all day long thursday so if you're
planning to use the 40 minute limit as
an excuse to keep it short
time to find another excuse yeah that's
awkward
blame it on the bladder gotta go
well okay so if your turkey goes wrong
you got insurance if you want to avoid
your family
now there's no excuses next it's been
the most challenging year
but people around the country are still
giving back
and i love this story so much from
kansas
a barber named nate riviera is
offering haircuts for turkeys for the
second year
in a row donate a turkey get a free
haircut
and this year's different though kovit
has shut down his barber shop
but nate and his wife erica are still
collecting turkeys
and sides for their families who need
them and in return meets offering a
voucher
a promise for a haircut when his shop
reopens
stories like this they really inspire me
and they're exactly what i wanted to do
this program for and if you're looking
for more ways to donate this season
go to our website we've got some great
ways to give back
all right and finally um jill you
actually
brought something i did um so i wanted
to get you a traditional
thanksgiving dessert to enjoy and
this looks like a normal cake but i
would say
why stop at one dessert when you can
have many
so introducing everybody the pie cake in
it's the turducken
of thanksgiving sweets if you lift your
cloche
this is the close it is
it's part pecan pie in a pumpkin pie in
a spice cake
with apple pie filling all in cinnamon
buttercream
with some oat crumble up on it oh my
i want to get everything all in one bite
the way nature intended
it's much better than a turducken oh my
gosh
sweets on sweets are better than meats
on meats oh
my gosh are so good
usually on shows i see people eating
garbage and i'm like how do they force
feed that but i'm genuinely inhaling
this
i want to thank jill i'm good i love you
you have a whole other pie cake in on
deck
and i just want to say something as
a cast member myself on odd mom out
yes you were so good it was the best
time ever
and i love this show so much i loved
being a part of it
and i really loved watching it so nice
well i love you and to everyone out
there
eat enjoy be happy be healthy be safe